chris cooley are you on the phone you
there I I am on the phone with you read
you the man you remember you remember
crisp during the lockout you helped get
us through the lockout on total access
by doing pottery that was like show for
for the TV show those know about this
was totally island I remember it like it
was yesterday are you still doing
pottery up with rich yeah and really
know are you still doing are you still
doing about himself yeah I remember that
dude do you remember the mugs Chris that
you promised us for years ago that
you're gonna make rich eisen podcast
mugs yeah yeah I uh I don't remember
that is there a card for chris cooley
anyway yeah we got one coming for you
all right Chris so you are you're not
doing pottery anymore still no I am
doing a hotter II I'm almost daily well
I'm actually going to the pottery store
as we speak side but you are not really
they have a weird that you should have
brought it up you're going clay shopping
right now Virginia buying clay losses
can be pasta stupid all right well it's
the perfect time to talk about colt
mccoy which will do when we come back
from break sound sounds good no I could
risk alright well put you back on hold
chris cooley has made a nice transition
from a long time Todd end with the
Washington Redskins to the radio voice
with Sonny Jurgensen calling games at
the Washington Redskins and he joins me
now on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Chris rich I'm doing great man it's nice
to be on the show if you thank you very
much on having me brother you're the man
thanks for coming on so is it gonna be
colt mccoy in in Dallas you think monday
night what do you think is gonna be colt
mccoy in dallas idea that robert griffin
might get some practice this week but I
guess unrealistic to see him play in
dallas right now i don't think there's
been enough prep for him coming off last
year or is her come back into the game i
think they have a body work to say look
you gotta have more than a week of
practice before you go in the game so
there goes cold McCoy's they think it's
the best
chance to win and Kirk Cousins it a lot
of nice things rich but see just in that
the confidence that key spots in the
game and he turn the ball over too many
times and too many bad turnover so you
get you get it Texas kid in Dallas colt
mccoy i know for the dreaded redskins to
but the two and five Chris I mean this
has got to be as disappointing as
starters you could possibly imagine with
rg3 getting hurt again and then Jay
Gruden trying to put Kirk Cousins in in
a spot that a lot of people thought was
perfect for him and he sort of did not
pass the audition and now here comes
Colt McCoy what do you think the future
of this team is even passed this year
with everything going on this year I one
of the biggest ideas from this year and
gruden was at the end of the year we'll
figure out exactly who our quarterback
is and what direction we're going and
that might be Robert Griffin well hope
it's gonna be Robert Griffin but then he
gets hurt and so use now wonder this
cult Kirk Cousins going to win a job
Kirk Cousins of good job so now you're
two and five and you're kind of a Nimbo
where you're actually going to be at the
quarterback thing it is a disappointing
start it's not what you want tell you
the amazing thing about this right now
is their top ten and often sand top ten
and defense so you're still doing five
and you're operating that to some extent
well he's not making plays and you give
the ball a [ __ ] so what what do you
think happens here Chris I mean you
can't evaluate rg3 with him with him off
the field here's what I think happens
rich i think Colt McCoy was brought in
to be rg3's back up for the next period
of time he was the number two something
was going to happen was Kirk at the end
of the year they wanted it to be a trade
but he did get a chance to play did get
a chance to win the job I don't think he
did that for Colt McCoy is the guy
that's the back up next year Robert gets
a chance to play Jay Gruden's gonna be
honest with him say look you're a read
option quarterback right now you're a
guy that's going to run the ball right
now you're gonna do what I want you to
do that's what you're best at and we're
going to try to win football games that
way and move forwards Roberts the only
thing you worry about there because you
hurt again is easy easy if you fragile
it's brittle is he is going to stay on
the field because if you do build your
office around Robert Griffin that's
entire
different than been building and often
surrounded I like kirk cousins or colt
mccoy different moving parts and so
they're somewhat of a risk there the
yellow probert one more shot of being
healthy one more shot of playing takes
advantage of that Chris thanks for
calling i appreciate it we'll get you
back on soon hey i'm such a good podcast
amazing buddy thank you chris cooley
that's chris cooley phoning in from
rural Virginia the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience